does a million way around actually have  the 11 tattoo speaking of that I do  indeed I have a seven tattoos I have one  on my back of flowers one on my  right here I don't know what my ribs a  one here and another one on my foot does  Millie boy Brown play video games I play  Sims 4 and I love it I like live mode  and I also like building homes in it and  I also have a vet in it so I'm just  leaving vicariously through my Sims  character I also like to play fortnite  from time to time but I  mostly Bush Camp until the very end of  the game until there's like five people  left and then I and then I hand the  controller over to an experienced  fortnite player to let them finish the  game so it's been it's been hard but I  don't really like video games I'm not  very good at them does really Brown no  martial arts  I wish I could say I do I think I got  like two black stripes on a white belt  that's not nothing yeah it's not nothing  exactly